it was something about when I put this
hat off and make me feel like Superman
well turns out Kanye West is actually
taking a step up up and away from
politics less than a month after this
happened if he don't look good we don't
look good this is our president he has
to be the freshest rapper went on a
lengthy Twitter spree to share why he's
had a change of heart
quote I've been used to spread messages
I don't believe in
I am distancing myself from politics and
completely focusing on being creative I
support creating jobs and opportunities
for people who need them the most
I support prison reform I support
common-sense gun laws that will make our
world safer I support those who risk
their lives to serve and protect us and
I support holding people who misuse
their power accountable I believe in
love and compassion for people seeking
asylum and parents who are fighting to
protect their children from violence and
war I would like to thank my family
loved ones and community for supporting
my actual beliefs and my vision for a
better world
they keep us so focused on history that
we start to believe that it actually
repeats itself and we become overly
traditional and we can't advance as a
race of beings we get too caught up in
the past and what everyone's saying and
what everyone's tweeting and sometimes
you just have to be fearless enough to
break the simulation it's been a very
controversial year for Kanye in May he
came under massive fire for calling
slavery quote a choice in August Jimmy
Kimmel left him stumped
there are literally families being torn
apart as a result of what this president
is doing and I think that you know we
cannot forget that whether we like his
personality or or not the his actions
are really what what matter
I mean you so famously and so powerfully
said George Bush doesn't care about
black people
makes me wonder what makes you think
that Donald Trump does or any people at
all
then in September he was booed during
SNL for making a pro Trump speech on
stage a white person these races well if
I was talking about racism I'm gonna
move down America
[Music]
then you get a situation where we need
to have a dialogue and not a diatribe
[Music]